in this video you're gonna learn how to
write this standard equation of a sphere
and you're also when you're given the
equation of a sphere you're going to
learn how to identify the center of the
sphere as well as the radius of the
sphere so let's jump into this lesson
the first thing you want to know is the
basic form of the equation of a sphere
the standard form and it's this form
here it's X minus H 2 quantity squared
plus y minus K the quantity squared plus
Z minus J the quantity squared equals
the radius of the sphere squared now you
probably recognize this formula if you
know the equation of a circle
we're just eliminating this last term
right here so center of the equation of
a circles is just X minus H squared plus
y minus K squared equals the radius
square but now we're working with the
sphere which is kind of like a circle in
three dimensions
you know you fear basically you know you
have a point here and then any direction
you go it's going to be the same
distance to the outer edge of that
sphere okay so that's the idea now the
thing that students sometimes make a
mistake with is that when you're looking
at this equation of the sphere that
these quantities here in parentheses
that H K and J the center of the sphere
they're going to actually have the
opposite sign so like for example if I
had a sphere that looked like this X
minus 1 squared plus y plus 4 squared
plus Z minus 10 squared equals let's
just say was 49 see here the center
would actually be a positive 1 negative
4 positive 10 right so it has that
opposite sign because it's X minus H Y
minus K and then the radius you want to
make sure that you're taking the square
root okay because this is the radius
squared to find the radius some students
mistakenly will square this quantity so
you'd want to make that mistake so let's
look at two basic examples the first one
say for example we want to find the
equation of a sphere with radius 3 and
center at negative 2 1 4 okay so
basically what we're gonna do is we're
gonna say X minus negative 2 squared
right plus y minus 1 the quantity
squared plus z minus 4 the quantity
squared equals the radius squared now if
I simplify a little bit see when you
subtract that's like adding the opposite
so we can really write this as X plus 2
squared
plus y minus one squared plus Z minus
four squared equals three squared which
is 3 times 3 9 and you've got it so
let's look at one more example here
they're gonna give you the equation of
the sphere so say for example here X
plus 3 squared plus y squared plus Z
minus 7 the quantity squared equals 100
okay we have to identify the center and
then the radius so here you can see the
center is actually going to be at not
positive 3 but negative 3 okay in this
case we just have Y squared so that
means the y coordinate of the center of
the sphere is going to be at 0 okay
because this is like Y minus 0 or y plus
0 and then here we've got Z minus 7 so
it's not negative 7 but the opposite
positive 7 so that's our x y&z
coordinate of the center of our sphere
and then the radius okay this is R
squared remember so we have to take the
square root okay to solve for R and you
can say in this case is going to be a
radius of 10 and you've got it so just a
quick video reviewing how to work with
the equation of a sphere
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon